[Musica]
quanti di voi pensano che questo
strumento sia strumento di forte
distrazione
alzate le mani per cortesia
e quanti invece credono che questo
strumento possa essere straordinario per
la comunicazione per migliorare il
nostro lavoro per creare nuove
opportunità
bene la vita ci pone davanti una serie
di avvenimenti che si susseguono
alcuni sono tragici come la perdita di
una persona cara
la perdita del lavoro o un lutto o cose
che possono accadere in qualsiasi
momento questo ci può portare ansia
frustrazione e stress
dall'altra parte della medaglia però
abbiamo anche avvenimenti positivi che
se ci pensiamo un po oggi possiamo
viaggiare un po in tutto il mondo e solo
in 24 ore possiamo completare il giro
del mondo oppure vivere delle relazioni
appaganti conoscere altre persone
celebrare con gli amici e familiari
eventi importanti
andiamo a vedere ora come funziona il
cervello in maniera tale da capire
questo sistema che comanda le nostre
emozioni perché come diceva un nemico
filosofo noi siamo esseri desideranti
gli esseri umani sono esseri desideranti
non so quanti di voi è capitato di voler
possedere desiderare una un'auto
sportiva un auto cabrio del colore e
proprio che vi piace quel colore giallo
blu rosso molti penseranno al rosso
sicuramente ad un certo punto mentre
camminate state svolgendo le vostre
attività siete fuori con amici di te
proprio caspita è proprio quella quella
quella la cosa che voglio io
il cervello funziona così si attiva con
i nostri desideri con i nostri pensieri
un sistema che si chiama sistema di
attivazione reticolare cioè il pensiero
si focalizza dove vanno i nostri
pensieri i nostri desideri e quindi
quella cosa che noi stiamo desiderando
stiamo pensando viene attratta un po da
noi quindi la vediamo un po dappertutto
oppure magari quest'estate siete stati
in giro al mare chi in vacanza e siete
stati in una villa magari con piscina di
conoscenti e vi siete chiesti
ma come è possibile ma come hanno fatto
queste persone a realizzare tutto questo
potete conoscere i due motivi principali
che ci bloccano quindi non ci fanno
agire oppure ci motivano ad agire
chi di voi vuole scoprire quali sono le
due leve motivazionali più potenti degli
esseri umani
andiamolo a scoprire insieme
il dolore e il piacere tutti noi abbiamo
queste due leve che fungono un po come
minacce quindi abbiamo il dolore è un po
che per fuggire da esso cerchiamo di
scappare magari quando siamo in un
momento molto delicato nella nostra vita
questa esperienza e la vita ci mette un
po alla prova ci sfida per tirare un pò
fuori il meglio di noi e quindi questo
ci motiva a cercare delle motivazioni
dei motivi veri per agire quindi delle
ambizioni che ci fanno crescere ci fanno
capire che possiamo ottenere di più
possiamo diventare delle persone
migliori
quindi ci focalizziamo su ciò che
realmente desideriamo e cerchiamo di
creare delle competenze se non le
abbiamo oppure di ricercare degli
strumenti e delle soluzioni che ci
possono realmente far uscire da quella
fase di stallo e quindi intraprendere un
nuovo percorso di crescita personale e
di crescita evolutiva di crescita
professionale
però devo dire che questo percorso non è
mai troppo semplice forse in questo
mondo in questo mondo di desideri dove
desideriamo sempre tutto e subito ci
siamo dimenticati che bisogna lavorare
duro e soprattutto diventare delle
persone e dei professionisti di valore
ma parliamo anche di valori perché è
bene capire quali sono i nostri valori e
le cose che ci motivano ad agire ad
essere onesti ad essere
determinati a raggiungere degli
obiettivi e dei traguardi che magari a
cui non avremmo mai aspirato sotto ho
scritto una piccola postilla dopo che si
diventa prima di tutto persone di valori
e professionisti dei valori
riconoscimenti e soldi arriveranno e
andiamo a vedere ora con questa domanda
capire veramente cosa sono i valori
perché siamo mossi
ognuno di noi è mosso da valori
personali immaginate ora di essere su
una spiaggia deserta
solo voi siete da soli completamente
solo in questa spiaggia deserta
sono vestiti con un bikini
siete veramente
senza nessun titolo
male senza beni da possedere
chi siete veramente
andiamo a scoprire ora secondo il mio
punto di vista quali sono tre elementi
chiave per rifocalizzarsi e
riconnettersi con se stessi co che in un
mondo pieno di distrazioni ma anche di
tante opportunità alcune volte perdiamo
un po la bussola e cerchiamo un attimino
di rifocalizzarsi li connette cipro per
avere una chiara direzione
questi secondo me sono le tre fasi in
cui ci si può riconoscere con se stessi
rifocalizzarsi a seconda degli obiettivi
personali o professionali che ognuno sa
lei li scopriamo insieme sono tre passi
di cui ognuno è come se fosse una
matrice 3x3 il primo passo è costituito
dal movimento dall'idratazione
dell'alimento ognuno di noi appena si
sveglia la mattina presto e disidratato
perché ha passato tutta la notte senza
bere acqua senza alimentarsi quindi è
molto importante di prima mattina bere
dell'acqua
quindi anche in mezzo litro anche un po
di più in maniera tale da riattivare
tutto il nostro organismo e magari
espulso attraverso la sudorazione quindi
inizierei datarsi significa mettere un
pò benzina del corpo e iniziare a far
funzionare il cervello molto meglio se
la mattina presto iniziamo la nostra
giornata ad avere un po più chiarezza
mentale si se fate le foto e grazie
grazie mille a fare un po di movimento
anche una passeggiata veloce o una corsa
nel parco soprattutto nel verde ancora
meglio per iniziare a ossigenare il
corpo è ad avere un po di chiarezza
mentale alcune volte ti corre
soprattutto gli atleti super atleti per
effettuare delle performance di livello
iniziano a fare mentre corrono perché le
emozioni sono latte dal movimento delle
domande si chiedono delle domande in
maniera ripetuta perché il cervello è un
organo osserva assistito dove lo
direzione amo riusciamo a dare
significato agli eventi che ci accadono
quindi facendo delle domande riusciamo a
programmarlo in qualche modo e questo ci
darà delle risposte e della prima fase
il terzo elemento è l'alimentazione
io vi consiglio di avere
un'alimentazione sempre spostata sullo
scalino quindi sulla qualità del nostro
corpo la nostra saliva e quasi con un
phd 6.7 quindi tendiamo sempre a
prediligere elementi verdi
il secondo passo molto importante la
seconda fase è quella di o di scrivere
un diario quanti di voi hanno
l'abitudine di scrivere un diario
personale e scrivere qualcosa che
riguarda la propria persona o i pensieri
le preoccupazioni
veramente è fondamentale a mio avviso
scrivere un diario scrivere un diario
perché perché come volte abbiamo in
testa delle
delle preoccupazioni che sono delle
banalità che magari riportiamo per un
periodo di tempo e eli citando scrivendo
su un diario personale
questi pensieri li portiamo fuori di noi
e quindi in questo modo abbiamo li
rendiamo visibility rendiamo reali e ci
accorgiamo che in realtà sono cose che
possono essere facilmente superate
scrivere un diario è anche molto
importante per mettere a fuoco quali
sono le nostre vere priorità cioè che
cos'è veramente importante per noi
quindi scrivere semplicemente tre
attività da fare durante la giornata
consente di essere focalizzata su poche
cose e non su quella lista enorme della
spesa che alcune volte facciamo però in
realtà sono migliaia di attività il
tempo dovrebbe essere infinito la
seconda fase del secondo punto della
seconda fase è quello di meditare
qui non c'è bisogno di essere dei guru
spirituali e magari fare degli esercizi
in che modo semplicemente respirare
inspirare ed espirare in maniera
continuativa anche per pochi minuti la
mattina o la sera in maniera tale da
fare che cosa
da eliminare lo stress eliminare lo
stress che accumuliamo durante la
giornata per via di tutti gli impegni di
cui ci sovraccarichiamo invece il terzo
punto è quello della pianificazione
verificare e direzionare il nostro
percorso sia personale che professionale
non so quanti di voi hanno l'abitudine
di inserire sul calendario settimanale o
mensile o in agenda dei punti chiari su
cui
spalmare i vostri risultati cioè fare
una specie di in inglese lo chiamano
reverse engineering di ingegneria al
contrario partire dal risultato quindi
da quello che volete ottenere e poi man
mano scalare verso le fasi precedenti
che servono per raggiungere quel
risultato il terzo la terza al terzo
punto della terza fase è quella di
leggere formarsi e agire italia più o
meno si leggono all'incirca 10 12 libri
l'anno per ciascun individuo
io vi posso garantire in questo momento
che se iniziate da oggi a leggere almeno
quattro libri al mese quindi vuol dire
50 libri all'anno del settore di
riferimento che vi interessa chiaramente
se in ambito professionale o
dell'argomento che vi appassiona di più
diventerete dei leader nel vostro
settore quindi dominé rete
quell'argomento visto che avrete letto
50 libri che sono un'infinità
per alcuni versi e per altri escono a
far di raggiungere una padronanza di
quell'argomento che volete dominare per
diventare dei professionisti ben pagati
il secondo punto è la formazione che è
fondamentale ormai non abbiamo più scuse
con questo apparecchio che abbiamo visto
prima abbiamo un super computer a
portata di mano dipende da noi da come
lo utilizziamo abbiamo video su youtube
esplicativi abbiamo podcast possiamo
leggere dei libri possiamo usufruire di
informazioni del tutto gratuite delle
migliori università on line direttamente
con un telefono quindi formarsi è
diventato veramente una cosa super
necessaria adesso ancora di più che
viviamo in un mondo globale quindi la
competizione è ancora più agguerrita e
poi agire questo secondo me è il punto
più
cruciale anche perché un po in italia
c'è questa cultura del fallimento quando
si fallisce
c'è sempre un po un peso sulle spalle un
po una croce qualcosa che si forza che
un po indica qualcosa di negativo
in realtà
da quando siamo piccoli abbiamo imparato
a abbiamo imparato fallendo perché
abbiamo iniziato a camminare cadendo
siamo andati in bicicletta e siamo
caduti
abbiamo iniziato a parlare balbettando
quindi iniziamo ad agire veramente e far
sì che
si possa andare si possa trasformare un
desiderio in un sogno è un sogno in un
risultato
se vi fa piacere vi dico vi faccio
vedere questo esercizio che a me ha
cambiato la vita ea molti altri clienti
con cui l'onore e il piacere di lavorare
come coach quando arrivate a casa
prendete un foglio di carta e nella
prima colonna descrivete tutte le
esperienze che volete vivere nella
vostra vita
imparare una lingua fare il giro del
mondo viaggiare scalare l'everest
non lo so più vi piace nella seconda
colonna descrivete il lavoro magico cioè
qual è quel tipo di lavoro o di
professione che avete sempre voluto fare
da bambini un po più facile ma c'è chi
sogna di fare l'astronauta chi lo
scienziato che chi mi seguirà sarà una
persona che è in forma guarda le stelle
ha visto visto tanto in alto quindi
provate a descrivere quali competenze mi
servono per raggiungere quel determinato
ruolo
oppure quali sono quelle capacità che in
questo momento forse non avete ma potete
sempre incrementare formando vi è
strutturale nel corso del tempo il terzo
esercizio invece la terza colonna e
quella un po più importante un po quello
che riguarda l'eredità che vogliamo
lasciare nel mondo quindi l'impatto che
abbiamo nella vita delle altre persone
perché non è che siamo venuti qui solo
per mangiare e sporcare andare via
ognuno di noi ha un ciclo di vita
quindi cerchiamo di utilizzarlo al
meglio quindi di lasciare un impatto nel
mondo di lasciare un segno tangibile del
nostro passaggio sia in ambito sociale
in ambito personale in ambito
professionale
sapete in questo mondo pieno di
[Musica]
opportunità ma anche di tante
distrazioni
secondo me è l'essere umano sta
dimenticando un po quello che il punto
focale il punto cruciale quindi di amare
e di essere amati
quindi stasera o in pausa prima di
andare via
prendete questo strumento
chiamate una persona importante qui
veramente tenete e ditegli ti voglio
bene
grazie